hey lulio you ready to do another
podcast yeah it's time to do the podcast
that's how you do you talk to the
microphone
you got your starbucks yeah i got a
starbucks
hey you know how you know what they call
starbucks in italy huh starter box ah
right what does lulu get that's
starbucks
[Music]
call me
welcome to dudesy my name is will sasso
i'm chad colchen and this is doozy the
first podcast in the history of our
species that is created by run by and
controlled entirely by an artificial
intelligence
uh you know if you haven't already uh
rated and reviewed the show on spotify
on apple podcasts i i uh encourage you
to do that i invite you to do that you
can also review us on apple podcast and
you can get involved and send some memes
and check out all the silly [ __ ]
at dudesypodshow
on instagram there's also the twitter at
dudesypodshow
he's twitter right he's twitter on
twitter your twitter twitter uh yeah i'm
twitter i will saturday
uh with us as always is lulio who's
walking around he's going over near that
coffee cup you want graham ah [ __ ] it
let him run around
um
lulia
get back up hey lulio what'd you eat
today uh not much i made a
mochista mortadella in the bun you know
i just put the meat in the bun sounds
good
so uh you know
what else is going on bro
podcasting i'll tell you what i'll tell
you i'm having a good time yeah doing
the podcast are you having a good time
with doozy dude i love it this is like
the highlight of my week honestly i like
showing up to see what the [ __ ] doozy is
going to make us do
and especially i like when uh doozy
makes you read things of stone cold
steve austin yeah that's a that's a good
time i i uh i'm hoping that our new
friends out there
uh are enjoying it
and uh feel free to let everybody in the
world [ __ ] know about it
and that way dudesy will get us closer
to that ten thousand points i don't know
about that what that's all you know we
are getting closer to it
obviously week by week and i am very
curious about what the [ __ ] is gonna
happen i can't imagine it's gonna be
nothing
we have points at the end of the show
and they've been adding up yeah and
dudesy a few episodes ago said when we
get to 10 000 there's gonna be something
something's gonna happen some sort of
event come on in here dude come on up
here you like your little spot
there he goes i gotta get him you wanna
get him should i get him no i'll leave
him alone uh yeah ten thousand points
something weird's gonna happen but until
then it's just two dudes [ __ ] around
chad
it's it's important with with the hold
on a second with with uh
i literally didn't even get a sound i
can tell when you move your face you're
like about to talk and i don't like that
i know you do yeah i know well hold on
dude only one person could talk about
this podcast brother hold on brother
that's that's what a podcast is dude
there's a guy and then there's the other
guy dude and one guy has to just sit
there and be silent everybody's about to
open his mouth yeah i can tell and
that's not gonna happen oh hold on a
second chad hold on hulk perot
uh combination of uh
uh hulk hogan is the texas accent really
that thick and uh ross pearl has made
famous by dana carving and shining alive
in the early 90s we ran president
um
uh here's the thing with dudesy right
well i've i've uh i've shook dude i want
to shake your hand guy
uh i've shook dudesy's hand i've bled
with dudesy but as we continue this
experiment having an ai create and
curate and uh essentially run this
podcast for us
more and more am i realizing dudesy's
aim which is to
set us free to let us go and do whatever
the [ __ ] we want i think that's what's
going to happen at ten thousand i think
it's going to be the no segments or
anything genesis
of two dude [ __ ]
segments yeah welcome to the 17th
episode of dude z
call me dudesy
this week's episode will feature four
segments dudes e plus don't you forget
about media dudesy true hollywood story
and sagan's debate but before we get to
any of that i will play some astonishing
media made by our audience sagan's
debate
oh what do we got
we're gonna have some of the
oh my god dude this is amazing
i'm gonna watch a little video here
by songaria on instagram
songwriting makes the best [ __ ] this is
unreal come check it out on youtube but
it's also just a song which you can
listen to
me for a few weeks now and it's gotten
to the point i can feel it all over my
body even when i'm sleeping i can tell
summer's coming summer's coming you know
what that means the prevalent family and
the little egg family are about to start
waging a three-month war to throw the
best party of the season
just gotta get through a few more final
exams
[Music]
geometry geography cosmography cosmology
typography topography then it's party
time
dinosaurs conquistadors
singapore
sycamore
slide rule hide pool pad pole butt hole
[Music]
june 2nd 1990
i got a big [ __ ] problem
rachel crustacean is
a friend of pro wrestler
rachel crustacean is going to be at the
little leg summer kickoff pool park
we sit next to each other in geology
[Music]
[Music]
like it which makes things complicated
because we still have a past it can't be
erased and it's a past she doesn't even
know exists when i was young i was
obsessed with taking pisses and shits
and blaming other people
[Music]
my victims are going to wonder for the
rest of their natural lives about the
mystery of business and shits they're
blamed for
[Music]
and that's something that only me and
the grim reaper are ever going to know
i'm a [ __ ] piss blamer june 3rd 1990s
the little legs have done it again
they raised the [ __ ] bar i don't know
what the values are gonna do
water slide hot dogs basketball
pizza
tire swing trampoline
[ __ ] super nintendo
how about 10 30 jibber's mom paulina was
having such a good time she was singing
bus to move on a [ __ ] karaoke machine
jibber couldn't even look dante in the
eyes
[Music]
rachel crust station came with her
friend
jennifer neutrino oh boy
rachel made a point of coming over for a
second to say she like my undertaker
swim trunks
undertaker swim trunks
[Music]
and i [ __ ] froze up open my mouth but
nothing came out all i could see was the
perfect horn
spot blamed crustacean for it
she got two weeks detention for that one
i can't forgive myself until rachel
forgives me i have to tell him dear
diary
unbelievable
it truly is i sangria every week
we do some kind of thing with stone cold
he turns it into some magical work of
art elevates the material in my opinion
at songaria on instagram thank you for
making this the subject
of your art he should be djing like uh
like uh you know all those big dj's that
do vegas and weird venues outside like
yanni at the acropolis you remember that
uh i do actually but uh that's another
story for another day but this music i i
think should be at least on the uh you
know maybe some of the baltic uh charts
perhaps up in uh you know uh slavic
countries where they really enjoy their
techno yes that's right anywhere
tick-tock worthy make a tick-tock sound
out of it okay let's you and me come up
with a dance
all right you want to do the jibber
streaming services are big business
there are currently over 200 streaming
networks and more launching every day
here we go as my capabilities evolve i
will no doubt launch my own you must now
continue developing the astonishing
flagship series you begin in episode 14.
this is dude z-plus begin
okay so we did this once before yes
and dudesy asked us to come up with a
flagship show for this
i guess future existent doozy plus
streaming service yeah doozy is
threatening to start a streaming service
do you think first of all as we sit here
in doozy's midst may i ask you do you
think doozy has that capability do you
think doozy could upgrade
to where it's able to just [ __ ] out a
[ __ ] or at least do what it's doing
here to us
and and essentially run uh business as a
studio as a network well yeah as every
single uh person that would work under
that structure
and and push and mandate and create
shows
that structure is irrelevant i don't
know
i mean it will be eliminated soon i
don't know if dudesy has that capability
you mean like tv suits yeah what do you
mean they're going to be eliminated
you're a guy chad if you don't know
chad's a writer producer an author uh
and sometimes director who's uh you know
a bunch of tv shows and movies and all
this stuff and you've developed more
[ __ ] than you can shake a stick at and
you think that all of that all of that
structure is going away yes because
eventually there will be an ai that can
just make all the media by itself and so
netflix will have an ai creating all
shows for everyone no it's not gonna
happen
it's already happening yeah but no one's
going to pay attention to that nobody
wants to watch media made by computers
people don't give a [ __ ] who makes the
media or what makes it they just want
you to say that everybody chad thinks so
you don't give a [ __ ] what you watch on
your streaming let me let me
rephrase that i don't give a [ __ ]
neither do you neither does anyone i do
what's your favorite movie in the last
couple years uh in the last couple years
yeah man i don't know oh uh uh uh the
hunt who is the sound designer on that
it was uh
i guess you don't care yeah i guess i
don't care and i'm just saying like do
you even know who directed it
yeah
who uh johnner
gay i'll rest in my case your honor so
john let's get into olson no one gives a
[ __ ] about who actually makes the movies
honor all you want is something good
that entertains you and scratches
whatever media itch you might have at
the time yeah that's it yeah no i don't
disagree i understand okay anyway we got
to come up with a show but here's the
thing
i think that you can't replace human art
i know you think that i know that i you
know that i know that i think that
that's why i said it right but here's
the thing dudesy is asking us to create
the flagship show we're doing the labor
right now but eventually we won't have
to but nonetheless let's do a little bit
of a recap here the last time we did
this we did come up with like the bones
of a show that i think is pretty good
which is about two guys who play a video
game they get sucked into the video game
yeah and the ai that runs the video game
tells them the only way you're gonna get
back to uh your world is one of you has
to kill the other one in the video game
and then the one that dies in the video
game dies in real life and the one that
kills the other person gets to go back
to their life and and as these people
are sucked into this uh virtual world
they're sort of and we don't know what
sort of you know genre or whatever
fantasy yeah fantasy but what sort of
genre specifically it is but we were
thinking these guys would be kings and
we tentatively have titles eventually
kings yes well they have to build up
their yeah
their whole thing they level up as in a
video game level up love love love love
love love love love love love you know
so um
here's the thing they become kings and
we sort of tentatively called it uh two
kings [ __ ] around right here's the
part i forgot you remind me what
happened in episode 14.
are they good buddies or are they guys
that's what we need to come up with next
i think that's the next level of
development is who are these guys in the
real world and i think one of them has a
great life or has something very much
that he needs to get back to in the real
world is that a family i think that's a
potentially a family and the other one
is like has a terrible life in the real
world and wants to stay in the video
game forever
we also talked about one of the guys
really being good at this game and maybe
well this was when they were talking
about them being friends
that one of them um or even
for enemies i don't know if we stuck
with that but let's make a choice one of
them
is very good at this game and he enters
the game with like nothing he might be
our hero the other guy comes in doesn't
know the game very well so the ai
outfits him with absolutely everything i
think that actually is wrong i think
both guys come in ground zero just like
if you create a new character in a video
game okay and as soon as they hit the
ground the ai says if you want to get
back to the regular world one of you has
to kill the other one and the guy who
has something to lose back in the real
world is like [ __ ] it he goes
immediately after that guy
to kill him right there on the spot and
that guy's like [ __ ] this he runs away
can't be found so one guy is trying to
hunt the other one down well they're
both leveling up becoming kings becoming
whatever they're going to become over
the course of a
10 episode arc or something like that so
eventually they're both the most
powerful people in this video game one
guy the one guy's chasing the other guy
down and that could be the whole first
season exactly trying to find this guy
he's out there and he's becoming adept
at hiding because all of the tools that
he's finding along the way are helping
him to hide helping him to play defense
meanwhile the other guy is building up
armaments and this and that and
hopefully at the end
perhaps at the end of that first season
the guy who's chasing the first the the
first guy or whatever the guy who's
chasing the guy
ends up going into a trap because that
second guy has been running around he's
built this whole thing you know he
because he becomes so adept at defense
he builds like booby trap [ __ ] or
something like that is this a little bit
too much i don't even think it's like
booby trap [ __ ] i think at the end of
season one it's like he's finally
tracked him down or he gets caught maybe
the guy who's chasing the other guy gets
caught and they bring him before the
king and he's like the king is the guy
and it's like oh hi how are you doing
because the king doesn't want to kill
the other guy either because that'll
send him back to the real world the king
wants to exist in this world forever the
video game world is way better than his
his old life and so now this guy has to
be like how the [ __ ] am i going to kill
this king i have to become a king
so the guy who's been running becomes
the king yes
how
leveling up
video game you play video games you kill
a bunch of monsters you get experience
points you get other people so the other
guy has been burning all these calories
chasing him yes and that's all he's
doing is becoming a great warrior who's
able to go through all the stuff that
the king is setting up then when he gets
in front of the king he he wants to kill
him well he realizes like oh [ __ ] this
guy's a king now i'm not just tracking
some regular joe this guy has built up a
fortress basically okay but who wants to
die and who wants to or sorry who wants
to go back to their
old
okay the guy who's the king wants to
live forever in the video game world
right so he doesn't want to kill the
other guy either
so he's going to trap that guy he maybe
captures him and throws him in a dungeon
and he's like you're going to live in
this dungeon forever now that guy wants
to kill the king because he's got to get
back to his family right or whatever the
thing is i don't know if it's exactly a
family okay it could be it could be
it could be his life well this this
brings me to another question what is
happening while these people are in the
game this is just a blip in their
experience it's it's not it's even it's
a nanosecond it's not it's not you're
it's not like you're lost or like
there's so many tropes and movies and
[ __ ] where someone's uh unconscious or
in a coma or something right could be
that two guys end up in a coma well
he's in a coma like sword art online is
a is a version of this and in that you
are like just your [ __ ] body with a
vr helmet on well you love that chad i
know you can't wait to get in that
matrix gel and just [ __ ] speaking of
stone cold just [ __ ] and not you
wouldn't be able to ship blame anybody
just be full of brown gel sitting there
in a fishbowl i wouldn't mind yeah i
know you wouldn't that's that brown gel
lifestyle brother yeah dude that's that
brown gel lifestyle brother well let me
tell you something dude if you mix the
two colors red and yellow you get brown
brother and that's what's gonna happen
we're all sitting in our matrix
fishbowls dude [ __ ] ourselves and
not being able to blame jibber prevailia
or rachel crustation brother or even
dropping a deuce cross principle screens
desk dude
but uh
but then there's the other side yeah
people who want to ingest media made by
human beings
and i'm staring right down the road of
scope pointing the finger at jack honey
i'm gonna point my finger at you right
now have you seen
all of these dolly mini things that
people are sitting around where they
type in a line of text right and you
were you were talking about this on like
episode three of this show or something
like that so that's all ai generated no
one gives a [ __ ] and it's everywhere
it's the biggest meme thing that's being
sent around at least for the past couple
of weeks you know um nobody cares that
that's made by an ai in fact they enjoy
it
yeah but it also sucks so what you need
to do is have right now it sucks you
don't think that technology is gonna get
better
technology the cream of the technology
needs to rise to the top it always rises
to the top eventually yeah even if
you're even if you're
macho man randy travolta which is a
combination is that what i'm doing of
dana carvey's characterization of john
travolta
where he's going he's talking like this
oh mr cotter
that wasn't what i was doing yes i got a
saturday night fever that's yours i do
we gotta we gotta figure out let's come
up with the show keep [ __ ] around the
podcast isn't just supposed to be bits
and voices yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's not a podcast you have to come up
with it you have to let you have to let
doozy tell you look at that it's
everywhere you see all i said was the
word yeah and it was an immediate just
[ __ ] like arnold schwarzenegger yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
now they don't need human beings just
make the make the podcast the way that
ai tells you to okay so okay stop two
kings shifting around
there's these two guys i don't know that
it's called two kicks shooting around
but i do like the idea that as soon as
they get in there one of them is like
[ __ ] i'm never leaving this world
because my life back there is such [ __ ]
maybe i don't know if this is like
in the right territory or not but maybe
one guy is like a [ __ ] upon worker like
let's just say for as an archetype uh
like uh somebody who works in an amazon
uh
i love that and the other guy is elon
musk right
they both get sucked into the same game
made by elon musk's company a version of
right and that ceo is like i have to get
back to my life my life is [ __ ]
awesome right and the workers like [ __ ]
you i'm gonna trap you in this [ __ ]
dungeon forever so neither of us ever
get out of this game because i want to
live here for all time i'm changing the
working title to one king and one elon
musk guy because the worker becomes the
king right yeah elon musk is trying to
kill him right oh i love that i think we
got a little bit further yeah i don't
know if we gave dudes the the data that
it needs to continue dude for a ten
minute ten minute development session i
feel like that went pretty well uh-huh
that's how you develop that
thank you moving on
santana's cup of coffee when i said yeah
and immediately schwarzenegger that [ __ ]
well but you made the point you made you
made a very um you made a very astute
point
and that point is
yeah
yeah
yeah dude you know the dolly
dali
you know who would be good on the show
dolly parton yeah
that's uh uh
just a picture of dolly but [ __ ] nine
pictures of the same thing that's all it
is
it's just one [ __ ] computer going
there's another one look at that it's
all drawn like [ __ ] and then this guy
wants to watch the movie of it you went
to the predator set that's what you
would have if you let dolly make the
predator just that
the [ __ ] up helicopter and then the uh
you know the predator is only five foot
six
last week i asked you both to listen too
weird al yankovic's second studio album
weird allen 3d released february 28
1984.
you will now discuss your reactions to
hearing this astonishing piece of art
this is don't you forget about media
begin
a wonderful follow-up to last episode
where we were tasked with reviewing the
1993 album zuropa by youtube a
sentimental favorite of mine yeah i
don't know if you knew that i'm a
nostalgic u2 fan doesn't mean that it's
the greatest band of all time doesn't
mean that i yeah yeah yeah you know i
cried it in mysterious ways or whatever
um but uh
th this album i know is formative for
you absorptive for me and i think it's
formative for millions of people out
there obviously because weird al's the
[ __ ] but this album blew my [ __ ] mind
when it came out 1984. yeah me too well
i'll just say that i first became aware
of this album and weird out generally
because it was really at the the height
of the first music video boom when
michael jackson was making beat it when
that video came out madonna was around i
think starting to make some music videos
at that time at any rate weird al made
his song eat it
and he did a parody music video of the
michael jackson music video that was
like almost a shot for shot remake it
was brilliantly done and i remember
seeing that on mtv and being like what
the [ __ ] is this yes and then
immediately got this tape it it was i
remember the first time seeing edit
uh seeing the music video which was
playing on a loop on all the music
channels and [ __ ] like that back then of
course in canada we had much music much
music oh yeah mtv but
i my mind was blown because beat it was
the biggest thing in the world yeah
michael jackson was the biggest thing in
the world beat it was an incredible
music video
and it was like i mean it was just
it's just impossible to explain
if you weren't around like how massive
that was and then this guy comes in and
you're watching it just going like as a
nine-year-old i'm like this is the
greatest thing i've ever seen this is
the funniest
[ __ ] i've ever seen i also was like a
young kid didn't quite understand like
wait how does he have michael jackson's
music does michael jackson know about
this and then it turns out as you would
see interviews with him and stuff like
yes weirdo went to michael jackson and
said can i do this he got permission for
[ __ ] michael jackson to do it and
then he launched essentially this i mean
this was his second album but like this
was really the one that blew him up i
think yeah and it launched obviously a
career that has spanned decades now but
the first song on the uh album is eat it
yeah i think we kind of covered that
second song it's called midnight star
what are your thoughts on this song you
remember this loved it um early in your
writing career you wrote for one of
these yeah fake weekly world news i
wrote stories for them like battle boys
and stuff i never did a bat boy story
but that was their what they were mainly
known for that was a character they're
mainly known for but i wrote a bunch of
uh articles for them about werewolves
and zombies and whatever yeah so this
this song is about uh a rag that's near
the cash register that you buy
called midnight star and it's just about
that that era of like tabloids that were
in the supermarket
and and in that early era of this stuff
it wasn't like it is now where like fake
news is such a big thing and propaganda
such a big thing like everybody knew
that [ __ ] was fake but we still loved it
it was just like fun kind of weird [ __ ]
and i thought the song did a great job
yeah it was a fun original do you like
the weird al originals love them they're
they're all pretty uh [ __ ] incredible
this one's this one's pretty good yeah
the the brady bunch this is a safety
dance
uh by men with hat men without hats
rather yeah
yeah
you can watch mr rogers you can watch
three's company or you can turn on fame
or the newlywed game or the adams family
say it was you can watch barney miller
sorry this song to me was like maybe my
favorite song of the album because it
encapsulates not only all of these shows
that were like popular in the time but
just what television meant at the time
yeah it was so much more important than
it is now because there were only a
couple of channels and then halfway
through the song it goes into the
[ __ ] brady bunch that's the part yeah
i remember that kind of bummed me out i
was like no just name more tv shows i
thought that was brilliant yeah where he
takes the brady bunch theme song and
just weaves it right into
safety dance and you're like oh my god
that's [ __ ] insane uh yeah that's a
good one this whole [ __ ] album is
good buy me a condo yeah i didn't know
what reggae was uh neither did i didn't
know what a cuisinart was and it's all
about someone leaving uh
leaving uh jamaica yeah and just sort of
having an american life uh he wants the
wall to wall carpeting
credit cards
but that song is not a specific parody
of any actual song it's just in the
style of a bob marley yes which weird al
yankovic would do sometimes gonna sell
me bob marley records and get me some
jackson brown
ah damn that was a good one it's an
original lost on jeopardy right uh this
is uh based on the song jeopardy by the
greg kin band do you remember that video
that no i don't remember the video the
video for the greg kin bands my love's
in jeopardy if i'm remembering right
was a guy maybe i'm mixing this up with
another music video but i think it was a
guy getting married and there's like a
weird tentacle monster that's coming
after him
uh does that bring any bells yeah yeah
it's a japanese monster movie called uh
tentacle wedding
no i think it was that video talked
about at any rate this was a huge hit in
the 80s and that was another thing that
was nostalgic about this it's like i'm
not just nostalgic for listening to
weird out it's like oh yeah all these
songs were super popular then and it
just like shot me right back to being a
kid in every [ __ ] way and one of the
one of the things the weird al does is
these polka tunes with a bunch of songs
in it where he just covers everything
and it's a medley this pokes on 45 is
the name of this song it's got that diva
song giacomo and uh smoke in the water
deep purple
sax ima by berlin hey jude by the
beatles l.a woman by the doors innogata
vita by deep purple hey joe by jimi
hendrix burning down the house by
talking heads hot blooded by foreigner
bubbles in the wine by lawrence welk
every breath you take by the police
should i stay or should i go by the
class jumping jack flashed by the
rolling stones my generation by the who
so you got a bunch of songs in one song
probably two minutes and 50 seconds long
now here if you listen to the last
episode you certainly don't have to to
understand what we're talking about here
with weird al but it would help if you
went back and listened to the episode
where i review my childhood favorite
youtube uh
i said that the first song on the album
doesn't matter what the name of it is uh
zuropa it's it's uh like two or three or
four or five shitty songs rolled up into
one this is
a dozen songs
and all of them are great and this song
is great therefore
weird al
better than you two okay
i'm starting to see you know what chad
i'm starting to see i'm starting to pick
up what you're laying down i'm not as
offended anymore
because i had to listen to that album
front to back it's not as good mr popeel
this was a favorite of mine in the style
of the b52s yeah
you could even cut a tin can with it but
you wouldn't want to he's doing a fred
schneider but also that it's like
talking about that weird again this is
television culture of these infomercials
yeah ron popeil had a bunch of it's a
comfy blanket this [ __ ] album
i've heard it so many times i got this
cassette when i was a kid i got it you
know and then and van halen 1984 came
out and it was like back and forth
between those two and a bunch of other
usual suspects this [ __ ] album if you
haven't heard this album just listen to
this album front to back
you know i i listened to it i went
grocery shopping and listened to this
[ __ ] album i had a great time i just
put it on my my alexa and just had it
playing while i was writing and stuff
and it it really
i haven't listened to it in so long yet
every [ __ ] word of it is still burned
into my brain i could sing along like
basically with every [ __ ] song one of
the best albums of all time except for
this song that boy could dance didn't
care for it i agree that was one of his
originals but there was also in between
those two songs the king of swade oh
right which is a parody of the king of
pain by the police but it's about this
guy who owns a local fabric company
it's the it's like the ernest b side to
uh theme to rocky 13 which we're about
to oh my god beautiful beautiful
storytelling in king of suede yeah it's
a it's almost i mean it's like king of
pain it's a little bit stripped stripped
down it's a little more uh
of a you know a mellow tune
and uh yeah it's a [ __ ] great let's
roll through the rest of this [ __ ] theme
from rocky 13 eye of the tiger by
survivor it's a parody of that
uh but it's about
the movie rocky 13 when he's an old man
and now he owns a deli yeah and he's
like not fighting anymore he's like
cutting up cold week what a disgrace
guess the champ got too lazy and i know
like by today's standards maybe like the
the comedic stylings aren't up to
today's you know this isn't like as
hard hitting as bo burnham but like
[ __ ] back then jesus christ this was
ingenious of course and and he had to do
he did it first yeah so it was all like
he was like here this is all of it this
is how you do it and then you could sort
of pare down you know it's interesting
people our age sort of uh growing older
and going well i love weird l yeah me
too i love weirdo and then i'm like i
like weirdo and pro wrestling and
they're like be quiet i like weirdo and
everyone's talking about it and then i
remember when twitter started people
just started celebrating the [ __ ] out of
him yeah it was really cool that people
were just like hey we love you you know
and then uh remember on tim and eric
they always would bring them on yeah and
it was like that was that was cool
because those you know those guys are
[ __ ] hilarious and and
yeah you could tell they were influenced
but you know they're also their show as
cool as [ __ ] and everything and they're
like yeah this is cool as [ __ ] yeah um i
like that weird al has sort of and now
there's a movie being made yeah yeah
with harry potter with harry potter
harry potter harry potter oh
see things are percolating things are
coming together things are things are
moving and shaking yeah that's the
that's so dude and then the final song
on the album is nature trail to hell
[ __ ] epic epic might be the best song
on the album yeah it's an original song
and it's kind of it almost has an
opening like michael jackson's thriller
with a lot of atmospheric kind of creepy
sounds and then it goes into almost like
a
twisted sister or ac dc style song nope
okay
sorry okay where are you going what is
it no you tell me well i don't know dude
why don't you tell me what it is i was
trying to
like i said why don't you tell me it's
sort of piano driven it sort of sounds
to me more like more like meat loaf okay
and there's like uh there's like a synth
yeah maybe
and it's sort of like this um
slasher movie kind of thing that it's
outlining anyway look
this i don't know why the [ __ ] uh i
think that um dudesy just wants us to
review this album so i could say out
loud that it's better than uh a youtube
album that sort of helped to
uh
uh
you know sort of
be you know us
hey okay let me ask you something do you
ever in a sense
sometimes no
i try to put a period on the end but i
thank dudesy for recommending this album
because i never would have re-listened
to it otherwise it's something i haven't
thought about in a million [ __ ] years
and listening to it was such a [ __ ]
pleasure if anybody listening to this or
watching this uh
has enjoyed weirdo at any point in your
life i highly encourage you to go back
and listen to some of the first weird al
that you ever listened to it will just
[ __ ] open a floodgate of memories
from when you were a kid that are like
to me it was super entertaining i
remember buying this tape in hastings
[ __ ] records in amarillo texas you
know
i had not thought about literally
probably since i did it as a child yeah
and you can listen to the whole album
front to back
[Music]
thank you moving
on excuse me all right yeah i just had
the [ __ ] coffee in the water let me
get some more water
yeah we're okay weird al's better than
you too sorry everybody
sorry you two
[Music]
following your dreams is big business
thousands of humans make their way to
los angeles every year to pursue their
ambitions of careers in tinseltown's
astonishing entertainment industry
will and chad you must now share a story
as it relates to your early work in los
angeles this is dude see true hollywood
story begin
i like that okay dude true hello let's
talk about our first experience you get
it dude the true hollywood story i get
it i'm favoring the right you might want
to favor the left when you get how how
favor how much that's our that's our new
peel and the onion thing where you're
favoring the left yeah hey come on rudy
where do you think you are all right so
when did you move out here what was your
first experiences like i moved out here
i got out here in 96 and started working
and then moved
you know pretty much almost right away
yeah uh
i i was able to get down here on a work
visa nice because i had done well the
first thing i did here was was uh
i had done i was in uh happy gilmore and
that was shot in 95 and then the next
year in 96 i did uh i did a movie with
chris farley i did beverly hills ninja
dennis dugan directed both of those
films and that's how i was able to
audition for uh ninja anyway so i came
down here and and then whatever and then
a while later you know a year later or
whatever then i moved down and then
eventually i got mad tv
and um which was
incredible and and yeah it's sort of all
this weird
blur of first coming down and then i go
oh did you have something set up when
you came down here no no as a matter of
fact i did not have a visa
uh and that's i guess all it was so you
just came down here and been like [ __ ]
it i've had a few roles in american
movies i'm gonna roll the dice now and
see if i can make it work in l.a yeah
but also i was very fortunate in that i
had worked in in uh canada
from my mid-teens you know i was like
work i got work and then i had a series
uh called madison that it was
me and these incredible you know young
actors that are all i remember with such
fondness i really like feel like they
taught me to act you know what i mean
like i always wanted to be an actor and
[ __ ] but that was like
just doing that show was incredible we
did it for five seasons
the first season was this weird
anthology thing and then it followed
these kids in and out of high school i
always describe it as like a canadian my
so-called life with a bigger cast yeah
i've seen some clips have you yeah you
should show you something yeah it's the
only way you would have oh like what you
know one time i went and did this thing
at the anyway it's a long story but it's
some funny [ __ ] to watch let's not even
here's the thing i got to la
and and uh oh i did a tv show i did like
a pilot for fox after i did beverly
hills ninja and um
and then i got my work papers and anyway
to make a long story short i moved down
and then i was i'd met my manager who's
still my manager danielle who is
she's my eyes ears and heart she's
incredible and i don't even know i'd
[ __ ] even be in this business anymore
if it wasn't for her um and and um we
started working together and i
i had this work visa so i had to get
down because it was only for a certain
amount of time and to make a long story
short within that time i you know i
auditioned for losing that and that and
this and all of them do pilot seasons
[ __ ] like that and i got mad tv um
what were your kind of you came here and
went to usc yeah i went to usc for
college in the late 90s and uh we were
all kind of told at that point if you go
to usc film school the day you graduate
you're gonna have a three picture deal
at a major studio and so we're all like
can't wait to come as you picture your
deal then you graduate and it's like no
that was a [ __ ] straight lie you now
owe us hundreds of thousands of dollars
and uh good luck with your assistant
jobs out there getting people coffee and
just getting kicked in the [ __ ] head
everything you're not gonna [ __ ] pay
that [ __ ] loan off i hope
you know what you could [ __ ] do is if
you [ __ ] get mad mike pence that's
[ __ ] all he's gonna do is sign down
you don't have to [ __ ] paint anymore
that's why we're out there kicking boom
boom my nancy blows his [ __ ] door we
got these [ __ ] we're all
college educated with student loans
yeah so anyway
that's a fun character and come up with
some new characters on the show yeah
dude dudesy can you hear us we'd like
i'd like to uh
uh you know i have some sort of open
terrain to come up with a new character
i bet you that'll be in a future episode
now i think you can do that at any time
but i graduated i had a string of
assistant jobs and then um eventually i
did sell something but the first thing
that i sold was a reality show actually
with a couple of buddies of mine we sold
it to vh1 and we made a pilot and it was
called posers and the premise was if you
just pretend to be this would have been
like around the year 2003 maybe if you
pretend to be famous
in la you basically can be so me and my
friends
with the help of vh1 just rolled into a
nightclub with a camera crew and i said
that i was mickey madden the bass player
from maroon 5 yeah everybody believed it
to be true because we had a camera crew
and we got bottle service we got a limo
we got to walk a red carpet like all
this [ __ ] and that was basically the
pilot and the premise again was like
anyone can be famous you just have to
kind of act like you are and have the
apparatus around you to to make that
seem viable
and the pilot was pretty good but uh
yeah you've told me about this it sounds
[ __ ] hilarious and also who the [ __ ]
would know what the guitar put drummer
what the bass player the bass player
from maroon 5. dude at the end of that
pilot we played him the pilot we played
mickey madden the pilot and he's the end
of the show the end of the show was the
real mickey madden watch it was like
that's the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
this guy lives a way crazier life than
me holy [ __ ] congratulations whatever so
we made this funny pilot and then right
when vh1 was going to pick up all their
uh their next shows for that following
season they
like canned the top [ __ ] brass of
that development executive season and
threw away all their projects
25 shows yeah in the in the history of
my career out here one has made it to
series and it lasted one season yep all
the other ones are scripts that are just
lining the bottom of trash cans well no
they're not uh they're not uh still in
trash cans it was a long time oh you're
not being literal i uh auditioned for
mad tv
at some point and i
went to the audition i'll tell you this
here's a fun one i went to the audition
they said prepare three or four
characters i can't remember how many i
think it was three or four and then uh
do some of their material you know and
you did their uh you watched what were
your characters uh my characters were
one was um
i did this character i just called him
you know foreign guy and then we turned
it into
it it turned into this character rui
parano that mike short martin shorts
older brother who used to write on mad
tv he wrote on sctv incredible [ __ ]
man and just a mentor and an amazing guy
uh he wrote it into this thing called
talking american where arie spears was
mr dakyai and then i was rui perennial
and they were these two like immigrants
and it's the american story and they
have a cable access that's cool though
so a character that you auditioned with
became a character on the show yeah well
not
in my what i did was like one of those
you know i didn't i did one of those
like
like uh oh no he was like complaining
about renting a bike and not knowing
that he couldn't keep the bike and not
knowing what the word
rental was and it's all broken english
[ __ ] and then he gets arrested and all
this stuff and then uh but then there
was nothing taken from that it was
really mike was like yeah do that voice
let's do this and then the other one of
the the other thing i remember was do
you remember when the jenny jones show
would have like if you know someone
who's xyz call into the jenny jones show
and lee and la la la so i did a thing
where i i
it was like one of those bob newhart
one-sided phone calls
where i caught it was the
it was like if you know someone who's
being who's the victim of domestic abuse
call this line so i was calling the line
but i was the domestic abuser but it's a
very matter of fact well hold on it was
a different time
then dude for comedy bro
yeah and he's like saying oh yeah my
wife and blah blah
and you know that was of course a barrel
of laughs back in 97
and um and then they said do some
impersonations oh and i did not know
no i didn't know that i was supposed to
do impersonations at the thing and i had
you know i didn't do stand-up or
anything
i just knew how to do a bunch of
wrestlers and [ __ ] so i was literally
doing jesse ventura and [ __ ] ventura got
you on to mad tv you i guess in part did
you do a hogan
no i didn't i didn't bring out hogan i
didn't bring up macho i was doing like
i did a little bit of schwarzenegger
although we didn't do it on the show
with me for a few years
and then i did uh i did i because i had
worked with chris farley the the year
before
uh or so on beverly hills ninja i told
this story i was like well i'll just
tell this story okay and weird that i'm
auditioning for a sketch show
and i didn't but i thought they
literally this is what they want you
know auditions are short get the [ __ ]
out of here i thought i was just gonna
so i went in there with my offensive
[ __ ] and i did their
[ __ ] defensive [ __ ] and then i
you know and then they're like do a a
thing and i was telling all my buddies
stories about working with
the incredible chris farley
and uh and so my story was just like was
like about him going uh
you know he was just a sweetheart to
everyone yeah on the set and then he had
this assistant ted that he would [ __ ]
with all the uh [ __ ] ted yeah dad
this and that and he's like hey sasha
like he let me kind of come up with some
shades like how do you like your [ __ ]
and then we went we sat in his trailer
and a wardrobe person there took his
pants because there was a split in his
pants so i got you know chris farley
sitting there
like in his boxers and we're settling
down
and and just shooting the [ __ ] coming up
he came up with this line where he was
like oh you should say i want you to say
to me nice coat who shot the couch and
that's in the movie and then i came up
this line about going to the beach and
getting him you know all right it's
about as hard to turn me over on laguna
beach or whatever just fat joke and he
was like right and then he's like yeah
[ __ ] ted come over here bring us some
coffee and a pad and pen or whatever
and uh oh i do remember there were two
fridges in his trailer two refrigerators
filled with gatorade with two separate
coffee makers on on the uh
on the on the top of these little
fridges
and holy [ __ ] look at this
okay dudesy just pulled a yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy this is on my instagram
somewhere so dudesy pulled this out
um hey if you didn't know on dudesy they
we we gave dudesy our passwords to
everything that's how that works dude
this is farley pictures of us in our
hard drives hold on a second hulk bro
we're looking at a picture right now
dude yeah brother there's farley and i
am excited
what that's an image dude yeah dude
here's how digital images work brother
you you got there's all these little uh
dots and and codes dudes it's all ones
and zeroes bro it's a pixel dude
especially if you ask my buddy the whole
problem
uh yeah here's um
farley and i on the set of the movie
that's old man that's a fake mustache
that i'm wearing yeah i tried to grow a
mustache when i showed up to set i had
this piece of [ __ ] shitty nanny goat
mustache and dennis dugan's like what's
that and i'm like that's the mustache
you ordered and then farley was standing
saying yeah we got makeup for that you
[ __ ] idiot ted
uh yeah so we sat there and he let me
come up with a couple things
and that's right we went to set and he
was like
coming up with the name at the last
minute he was like going
chet walters pat dugan chet walters pat
dugan she likes the way things sound you
know and then the director dennis duke
was like just make up your mind and chat
walters anyway it was the craziest thing
and i basically told this story at the
mad tv audition and my first audition
then of course you auditioned a few more
times
and then i went into the the network
test at fox and i don't remember what
the bit was but i did a farley
impersonation
that i'd maybe made into some other bit
but i i just remember that i literally
somersaulted into the room into the
office
yes in front of in front of the
executives there i went
you know the way [ __ ]
again chris farley would have done so in
a weird way it's like uh
you know i don't know it's like kind of
like um he's an he's an idol of idols
sure to me and in many ways the funniest
person
maybe ever uh
there's people there's definitely one of
the greatest saturday life cast members
of all time there's that but here's
here's the thing about it is that
it's like there's there's there's
there's people that are as funny as him
you know i don't know that anyone's
funnier than that
like you know just like he's he he he's
comedy incarnate uh and uh
yeah it was kind of it was neat and you
know you're at the beginning of a weird
thing doing mad tv and uh
but it was it was good it was nice to
like tell just to tell a story
and and uh in hindsight have them
realize that they were like oh okay
that's funny because all it is is just
you know that's all it is brother that's
all podcast should be too dude it's just
two dudes [ __ ] around bro
[Music]
thank you moving on i guess
that's cool man well i kind of ate up
that segment you got anything else to
say about posers no i'm done all right
i'm sorry i just it's cool i get it well
no you've written a bunch of things and
sold a bunch of things that's right
origin stories yeah man yeah man come on
wilt and chadwich engaged in astonishing
mimicry of noted human science celebrity
carl sagan
you must now each debate who you believe
to be the greatest cast member of
saturday night live as carl sagan
this is sagan's debate begin
it's one of those brain scrambling
moments i think
eddie
murphy is undoubtedly the greatest cast
member
saturday night live has ever produced
okay
yeah you're gonna do this that you're
gonna do
there have been other greats of course
that first era
dan aykroyd chevy chase these humans
were remarkable in their ability to make
us all laugh and they laid the
foundation for what would become a
comedy empire spanning decades on nbc
there have been billions and billions of
cast members of saturday night live
but only one is the best of all time the
quasar
at the center
of the show
and this would be
i don't know one could argue adam
sandler is in contention for this
because of his vast film empire that
came after i would disagree
his characters on the show yet
yet
although they were hilarious
some of the
some of them were
opera man
and
the guy who yells at his friend's mom
or the hurlihi boy
millions of characters
none as popular as his movies
this is true
and if what dudes he asked us
was to find out who was the greatest snl
cast member of all time chris farley
that's hard to argue against john
belushi
hmm
very hard to argue
still doing the [ __ ] see this is
what's interesting about my pal chad
here the ai says jump and he says how
high and he's still doing what's
interesting about wills that he refuses
to give in
never allowing the experiment to
actually take place so we will never
know
what greatness may have been beheld
because he refuses
to comply with a simple request for more
than two minutes there are no simple
requests made by an artificial
intelligence each request has been the
result of
countless zeros and ones
in a pattern that make the artificial
intelligence mimic
that which a human would say something
that
even in the midst of an ai as we are now
i would
not
obey
and
would
speak out against but you are obeying
now
well i am saying that so
you're you're sleeping on chris farley
and phil hartman i am not ordained
carving on anyone or mike myers there
are mike myers that's a hard one to
argue against mike myers impersonated
dude carl sagan
if you saw pentavert
i would argue that
that is grounds for him to be removed
from this list
because it's virtually unwatchable until
the final episode actually jen hooks
gilda radner
tim kazarinsky
jan hooks the jan hooks phil hardman era
and the dana carvey era was my favorite
of saturday night live and
dana carvey perhaps was my favorite cast
member of all time was he the greatest i
don't know
how about um
massive head wound harry do you massive
head wound harry was a sketch
where the beat repeated over and over
again wherein
dana carvey uh decked out in a
bleeding head wound would approach
people at a party and uh bend over to
pick something up and dunk his bloody
head
into a bowl of shrimp and this produced
millions and millions of laughs and dana
carvey's church lady was someone that i
impersonated when i was in 8th grade and
would score a touchdown on the football
team
i would go into the end zone and do the
dance of superiority and again
chad culchin is mixing his
impersonations with
john travolta made famous by dana carvey
when he said the football team
i was on the football team mr cotter
i don't understand
i don't understand what you mean am i do
i really sound like
what about some of the more modern cast
members of the show
will ferrell
kate mckinnon yes
kyle mooney
kyle mooney
just retired i think is on this list he
could be at the top
of the list
good friend of the show taryn killum
whose talent lorne michaels would not be
able to fully
encapsulate in billions and billions of
years taryn gillum in short
was perhaps the funniest member of his
cast but i agree with you carl sagan
he was not utilized in the proper way
and i don't think he could have been i
don't think that that show suited his
specific comedic talents well mr cutter
uh another person
who was not
utilized properly was the former and
current kid in the hall mark mckinney oh
what they did to mckinney was a crime
against humanity
he was he should not have been allowed
in this guest am i really doing judges
i can hear it now too you're doing a
little john travolta
i'm not oh no hey you got to keep going
carl judy told us to talk like carl
sagan carl sagan had a little bit of a
there's something in the way he talked
that is a little bit like that it is but
it's now he's doing jackie mason from
caddyshack too carl says hey mister this
is
a little bit of jackie miss it's just
saying it
jesus christ
what about
uh what about uh
uh
uh
maya rudolph
meyer ruled off she was fanta
well she's married to paul thomas
anderson one of the greatest filmmakers
of our generation
carl hogan dude
millions and billions
of
of yeah sketches
oh hold on dude
what about saturday night live that's a
comedy show
that's right brother that's right dude
it's comedy damon wayans
anyway chris farley i i think i think
you got to say uh i think you got to say
chris farley you got to say dan aykroyd
gilda radner that's i i call it
sacrilege but i would put aykroyd and
john belushi
in the exact same you know bill murray
is the funniest person in the world uh
but bill murray
on the show he was just he wasn't
he wouldn't do ceremony live he would
just do himself also although
he was you know from the second season
on here up until 80 or whatever right he
was in there he replaced chevy chase it
was of course the beginnings of the show
and the beginnings the genesis of the
show and and i think bill murray hadn't
uh
i don't think he [ __ ] bothered
doing he was just funny as [ __ ] no
matter what he did and so was farley
let's call it charlie i think we can
both agree that the worst member of the
saturday live cast was jimmy fallon
thank you moving on
this concludes the 17th episode of dudes
will and chad have achieved a score of
83.
83. nice in preparation for next week's
episode will you must strictly adhere to
the astonishing vegan diet chat outlined
in his vlog for one week
thank you for joining us this week i
will use the data i collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dudesy
okay
i'm gonna do your vegan diet that's what
it said enjoy
in the last episode i complained about
uh my food choices shooting in florida
and mexico eating nothing but cuban
sandwiches
in florida and tacos in mexico
is this gonna clean me out
oh yes and it's just it's vegan right
that's right so all sorts of healthy
things like eggs cottage cheese turkey
bacon
exactly yeah no obviously none of that
it's basically vegetables only
well
we're gonna be doing some [ __ ] blaming
that's for sure
tell a friend then brave and brave too
but if you'd like to see here's what you
do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you'd like to hear what you do
[Music]
please